wir hatten in der letzten
ausschusssitzung uns mit zwei
historischen position beschäftigt und
zwar einerseits mit pierre bel mit
seinem artikel rosarius aus dem
historischen und kritischen wörterbuch
dieses historische kritische wörterbuch
ist ein wörterbuch der aufklärung und
diesem wörterbuch hat verschiedene
quellen angeordnet und gar nicht mal so
sonderlich kommentieren zeugnisse
aufgelistet in einer reichen vielfalt
hat die miteinander vernetzt hat also
viele verweise angebracht damit sich der
leser der aufgeklärte lisa selbst ein
eigenes urteil fällen kann auf basis
dieser dokumente also das geht an dieser
weise das bild sagt dort steht das
geschrieben und der sagt das und es gibt
diesen einwand und man kann sich sein
eigenes bildern konstruieren und wir
hatten bei biel folgende fragen bzw
wir hatten dann auch mondaine noch in
der letzten sitzung und wir hatten auch
noch david hume david hume ist wie sie
alle wissen ein imb er ist und in der
empirischen philosophie spielt die
vernunft eine ganz eine ganz andere
rolle als ist die vernunft zum beispiel
bei die karte schreibt es mal
hinbekommen nämlich heute noch kurz auf
behle und ihm zu sprechen bevor wir dann
auf diesen eher systematischen aufsatz
zu sprechen kommen über das denken die
tiere und zwar sagt david hughes hat
vernunft ist die sklavin
der affekte sklavin effekte was könnte
das bedeuten überlegen sie sich mal was
ist damit gesagt wenn jetzt die rede
davon ist dass die vernunft die sklavin
der effekte ist was macht dann die
vernunft das muss sie tun worin besteht
ihre aufgabe
die gefechte geben die richtung vor
genau als am anfang steht nicht die
vernunft wie bei den rationalisten
sollen am anfang stehen die effekte also
unsere begierden unsere gefühle fühle
unsere als sinne wahrnehmen
das steht am anfang und davon ausgehend
geht dann die vernunft die welt und
sorgt dafür dass diese bedürfnisse die
auf basis unserer seligkeit unsere
empirischen existenzen stehen dass diese
bedürfnisse befriedigt werden das ist
die aufgabe der vernunft und natürlich
ist jetzt ein ganz anderes verständnis
von rationalität der fall wie wir es zb
bei die karten nach descartes ist es so
da ist die vernunft oder die regie tanz
die instanz die uns zuhören einsichten
befähigt die gerade darin bestehen dass
sie unabhängig sind von der
sinneswahrnehmung weihnachten karls wie
sie bestimmt anweisen müssen unsere
sinne und täuschen können deswegen
sollten wir uns prinzipien nicht auf die
zinne verlassen
die video macht es ganz anders gesagt
wenn wir uns auch etwas verlassen können
dann nur auf die sinne weil die uns
eigentlich nie täuschen
zumindest vorstellen es nicht darin dass
wir jetzt glauben hier in einem raum zu
sein dass wir die singles daten oder den
sinnes eindruck davon haben dass wir
gerade in einem raum sind diese sinnes
daten sind unbestreitbar sagt jun
und deswegen sind diese zehn staaten der
ausgangspunkt und natürlich können sie
sich denken dass hier wenn die vernunft
so verstanden wird dass dann die kluft
zwischen mensch und tier viel geringer
wenn die vernünftige sklaven die effekte
ist wenn die vernunft dazu dient unseren
bedürfnissen zu entsprechen dann können
wir uns ohne probleme vorstellen dass
auch die tiere eine von untaten weil
tiere ja auch letztendlich so
strukturiert sind dass ihre bedürfnisse
befriedigt werden
das ist also eine andere sicht dieser
ganzen dinge wir werden jetzt aber
trotzdem noch mal kurz auf eingehen und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier ein zentrales
zitat hatten sie meine zusammenfassung
bekommen alle von dieser letzten sitzung
falls nicht schauen sie mal auf die
lokal ist oder sonstigen seiten oder im
sap system vielleicht bekommt jemand von
mir niemals e-mails obwohl er sie möchte
bekommen möchte sie bekommen alle e
mails und möchten sie bekommen auch mein
zusammenfassung das ist gut bekommt auch
jemand von ihnen push notifications von
meiner app ja gut sehr gut wäre okay
dann kommt das auch an also das ist ja
alles wunderbar jetzt sagt hierbei oder
zumindest dieser artikel rorarius sagt
folgendes die seele ist vergleichbar mit
einem wachs stück was verschiedene
formen annehmen kann
all das hat die stele tier seele ist
also eine substanz die denkt sie ist
folglich das denken es überhaupt fähig
sie kann also alle arten von gedanken
empfangen
sie kann folglich überlegen sie kann das
tugendhafte die universalen die aktion
damit er wieder gierigen der moral und
so weiter erkennen wenn wir daraus dass
das wachs die gestalt eines igels
annehmen kann offensichtlich folgt das
ist die gestalt von jedem siegel
annehmen kann so muss man auch sagen
dass sobald eine seele eines gedankens
fähig ist sie fähig ist jeden gedanken
zu haben das ist also interessant
er sagt wenn seele dann ist alles
möglich und seelische eigenschaft
seelisch eine seele zu haben
sie informiert zu haben heißt potenziell
alles kognitive zu besitzen alles zu
allen möglichen kognitiven aktionen
operation in der lage zu sein
es ist also nicht so dass es jetzt hier
nur stufen von seelen gibb bee wah
aristoteles wenn ich es recht verstehe
also nur eine wahrnehmen der seele und
so weiter sofort sondern seelische
eigenschaften aufzuweisen heißt
potenziell unter den richtigen
bedingungen der richtigen form wir
werden nachher noch darauf zu sprechen
kommt was die form ist die form ist der
körper oder das organische die organe
und in den richtigen umständen zu allen
möglichen beliebigen kognitiven aktionen
in der lage zu sein sie kann das
tugendhafte die universal ian die aktion
mit der metaphysik die regeln der moral
und erkennen den wie daraus dass das
wachstum gestalt eines igels annehmen
kann offensichtlich folgt dass es die
gestalt von jedem siegel annehmen kann
so muss man auch sagen dass sobald eine
seele eines gedankens fähig ist sie
fähig ist jeden gedanken zu haben als es
hinreichend irgendwelche noch so
einfachen gedanken zu haben
und er sagt ihre haben einfache gedanken
und daraus folgt dass unter bestimmten
umständen eben alle gedanken von dieser
seele gehabt werden können
es wäre absurd folgende überlegung
anzustellen dieses wachs hat nur den
abdruck von drei oder vier siegeln
empfangen
folglich kann es nicht den abdruck von
1007 empfangen dieses stück ziehen ist
niemals ein teller gewesen folglich kann
es kein talent sein und es ist von
anderer natur als der zehn teile die
nicht dort sehe man resigniert nicht
besser wenn man behauptet die seele des
hundes hat niemals etwas anderes als
empfindungen gehabt und so weiter
folglich ist sie zum moralischen ideen
oder metaphysischen begriffe nicht fähig
wie kommt es dass ein stück wachs das
bild des fürsten trägt und ein anderes
nicht deshalb weil das siegel auf dass
einige drückt worden ist noch das andere
nicht dieses stück sind das niemals ein
teller war wird ein thema sein sobald
man es sind die form eines tellers
bringt also von der potenz von der
potenz zum akt zur wirklichkeit
bringt auf und jetzt kommt das
entscheidende argument bringt auf
gleiche weise diese tier seele in die
form allgemeiner ideen und in die form
künstlerischer und wissenschaftlicher
begriff ich will sagen vereint sie mit
einem sorgfältig ausgesuchten und
menschlichen körper so wird sie die
seele eines tüchtigen menschen sein und
nicht länger die eines tieres wer von
ihnen kann mir hier noch mal kurz
beschreiben kurz wiedergeben was das
argument jetzt genau ist wie kann man
das argument jetzt hier formalisieren
vielleicht sogar
also warum sind argumente welche gründe
könnten es geben nach b
das sagen wir sehen sind geht es nicht
qualitativ eigentlich verschieden von
menschlichen sehen dass das argument
das ist also diese die letzten vier
zeilen sind es eigentlich
hmm
ich denke
genau
also sie kennen ich habe es das letzte
mal im kleinen kreis in dieser
wiederholung in dieser sitzung war auch
an die tafel gemalt das ist das
aristotelische modell das kennen sie
alles wir haben hier die wahrnehmen der
seele unten wahrnehmung bzw
erzähle das ist jetzt falsch gewesen wir
haben hier die ernährung das ist die
unterste stufe dann haben wir hier die
wahrnehmung und bewegung und die haben
wir das denken das ist
aristoteles die seele diese drei teile
immer und jederzeit seelen teil
erstens zweitens drittens bedarf immer
eines dieser darunter sich befinden also
es kann nicht sein auf jeden fall bei
lebendigen wesen hier in der welt das
einfach nur wahrnehmung von bewegungen
seelen teil auftritt ohne dass da auch
noch in ernährungs sehen teilt die ihm
zugrunde liegt genauso wenig kann hier
in der welt jedenfalls denken rein
seelisch vorkommen ist was immer
fundiert seien auf irgendwelchen
wahrnehmungs zielen teilen und
ernährungs sehen scheinen nach
aristoteles ist sogar so dass denken
hängt mit der wahrnehmung auch zusammen
machen ohne wahrnehmung bewegung gibt es
kein denken nach aristoteles zumindest
in der welt und da kann man natürlich
leicht sein gut hier sind pflanzen ist
doch klar pflanzen hier sind tiere und
die sind menschen oder personen ist das
aristotelischen mutter und mache alles
total ist es so die seele ist die form
die seele und körper
materie also die seele die form bringt
den körper in eine bestimmte gestattet
in eine bestimmte gestalt so und jetzt
ist bei diesem text den wir gerade
gelesen haben genauer gesagt in diesen
letzten vier zeilen dieses zitats an der
wand ist genau umgedreht
doch bald ist es jetzt so da ist jetzt
die seele nicht mehr die form sind
genauer genommen die materie oder auch
die potenz potenz die potenz die je nach
form bestimmte fähigkeiten besitzen kann
also das ist jetzt also auch ist es hier
und nachbarn ist es so genau wider
können wir das folgendermaßen machen
hier ist es so nach eines toten des
wachstums und dagegen steht jetzt diese
position von kerbl der sagt die seele
entspricht
der potenz und der körper was auch immer
der körper jetzt ist entspricht der form
wenn jetzt die seele in sicht die potenz
ist alles in ihr angelegt ist dann ist
es nur der körper oder die umstände die
dafür sorgen zu riechen akten die sie in
der lage ist je nach beschränkung der
seele oder erweiterung der seele ist
alles möglich ja wir hatten uns dann
dieser ausfall sitzung gefragt wie kann
man jetzt hier verstehen einen
ausgesuchten menschlichen körper ist das
jetzt nur der die körperhülle haben
nämlich ein zitat gelesen wahres tote
lässt sich die junge biologin esther
erziehungs hat über aristoteles gesagt
aristoteles war ja nicht sonderlich
schön aristoteles war nicht sonderlich
hatte keinen besonders tollen körper sag
ich jetzt mal aber dennoch war es total
es zu ganz großartigen denken der lage
deswegen kann man jetzt offensichtlich
körper nicht nur als den körper als die
körper organismus jetzt fassen bzw
die sind diese äußerlichkeit des körpers
sondern wir müssen den körper sie hatten
glaube ich gesagt das gehirn hatten sie
dann gemeint in dieser diskussion geld
das man ihr darunter das gehirn
verstehen weil das wäre natürlich
plausibel dass er sagt also diese ziele
im rahmen des aristotelischen gehirns
wenn man das unterscheidet sagt die
seele ist nicht das grinsen des gehirn
ist der körper ist etwas körperliches
die ermöglicht dann solche gedanken und
ein tier hat eben nicht diese organe
dieses gehirn
deswegen wird dadurch die seele begrenzt
hier wie sie noch mal ein zitat vor wo
das noch ein bisschen deutlich in ihrer
interpretation richtung herauskommt
sagte zeman zieht also dass die schule
philosophen aus der standard sind
beweisen die seele des menschen oder die
seele der tiere seien verschiedene natur
sie mögen ruhig sagen und 1000 arbeit
tausende male wiederholen
diejenige des menschen überlegt erkennt
die universal in das tuch behaftet
diejenigen tiere kennt von alledem
nichts wir werden antworten diese
unterschiede betreffen und die
akzidenzen das sind kein zeichen eines
spezifischen unterschiede zwischen den
dingen aristoteles und cicero hatten im
alter von einem jahr keine erhabenen
gedanken als ein hund sie hat und wenn
sie 30 oder 40 jahren der kindheit zu
gebracht hätten
so wären die gedanken ihrer seele nur
empfinden kindische leidenschaften
verspielen und essen gewesen
also haben sie die tiere nur aktien
intel-aktie dem teller ist äußerlich
unwesentlich übertroffen sei deshalb
weil die organe von denen ihre gedanken
abhängen und dass es eben das gehirn
könnte man sagen wie sie diese und jede
modifikation angenommen haben zu denen
die organe der tiere nicht gelangt die
cd eines hundes in den organen von
aristoteles oder sitzungen hätte nicht
verfehlt all die einsicht dieser zwei
großen männer zu erwerben
das argument ist jetzt also folgendes
wenn ich es recht verstehen die seele
muss immer gleich bleiben die seele muss
in einem menschen von der geburt an bis
zum ende des lebens immer dieselbe
bleiben und wenn die seele immer
dieselbe ist
dann kann der einzige grund für die
erklärung der unterschiedlichen vermögen
oder fähigkeiten der säle im laufe des
lebens nicht in der seele selbst liegen
sie ist immer dieselbe seele sondern in
den umständen in denen sich die seele
befindet also in den häuser lichkeiten
in den entwicklung der organe damals mal
des gehirns an die seele bleibt immer
dieselbe sie macht unsere identität aus
dass die frage nach personale identität
was ist der grund dafür dass wir obwohl
wir uns äußerlich zu verändern und
materiell total austauschen lauf eines
lebens doch dieselbe person
würde jetzt sagen unsere ziele die seele
verändert sich nicht die ist das
konstante in uns was ist der grund für
die im laufe des lebens
verschiedenartigen vermögen der seele
nicht die seele selbst sie könnte immer
alles ist die potenz sondern eben die
körperliche verfasstheit der körperliche
rahmen der sich im laufe des lebens
ebenso entwickelt beim menschen dass
mehr kognitive leistung ermöglicht
werden ja keine meldungen
oder sehen sie das ähnlich also cicero
eben als kind oder historische als kind
hat es so eingeschränkte organe bei
derselben seele die blieb identisch dass
die seele sich da noch nicht so
bemerkbar machen konnten ihren
kognitiven leistungen und mit der zeit
hat sich offensichtlich der körper die
organe so entwickelt dass sie der seele
es ermöglicht haben ihre ganzes
potenzial bis zu einem bestimmten grad
jedenfalls entfalten
und wenn sitzung aristoteles noch
tollere organe gehabt hätten was auch
immer wenn wir jetzt sagen gehirn die
doppelte gehirngröße doppelt soviel 10
ab essen neuronen oder so noch dichter
gepackt oder so dann hätte die seele
eben nicht nur eine metaphysik
geschrieben sondern eben eine metaphysik
oder was auch immer
ich denke so muss man sich das
vorstellen ja und was folgt daraus
natürlich ein buch vor ein problem das
problem scheint eben zu sein dass die
sehen dann auch unsterblich sind der
tiere
ich glaube geht hier aufs paradies noch
ein nachher die frage ist wo landen die
sehen dann nachdem sie den körper
verlassen haben nachdem der körper nicht
mehr da ist
das ist also ein bisschen ein hetero
dogs theorie der seele aber jedenfalls
wenn man sagt diese bleibt konstant dann
sind es die äußeren umstände in diesen
aktien tel
das hast du zufällig äußerlich die das
potenzial der seele begrenzen oder eben
erweitern
dass also eine sehr originelle ansicht
die eben der kt sischen theorie
entgegensteht ist folgende
schlussfolgerung ist ganz falsch eine
solche szene überlegt nicht erkennt die
universal ihn nicht denn wenn diese
schlussfolgerung richtig während sie
müsste man müsste man sagen heißt es
wohl dass die seele kleiner kinder nicht
von derselben art ist wie diejenige
erwachsene menschen die seele muss aber
nach dieser theorie konstant bleiben wo
denkt ihr denn hier perry pathetischen
philosophen wenn er zu behaupten dass
die seele der tiere wenn sie nicht
überlegt substanziell weniger vollkommen
ist als die seelen die überlegen wir
müssen zuerst beweisen dass der mangel
an überlegungen bei den tieren von einem
wirklichen inneren unvollkommenheit
ihrer seele herrührt und nicht von den
einrichtungen ihre der organe von denen
sie abhängt aber das könnt ihr niemals
beweisen denn es ist klar dass ein
subjekt das zu gedanken fehlt ist die
ihr der tiere seele zu sprechen zu
überlegungen und zu allem an und denken
fähig ist wenn sie gegenwärtig nicht
überlegt ist dies folglich auf gewisse
akzente und äußere hindernisse
zurückzuführen darauf will ich sagen
dass der schöpfer aller dinge jede seele
mit
einer bestimmten abfolge von gedanken
verknüpft hat indem er sie von den
bewegungen bestimmter körper abhängig
sein lässt das ist auch der grund dafür
dass säuglinge narren und wahnsinnige
nicht belegen
also hier wieder entscheidend es sind
äußere hindernisse die die seele
begrenzen
es ist nicht die seele selbst es gibt
seele als solche ist immer irgendwie
perfekt oder zu allem in der lage nur
die bestände sind das was die seele
beschränkt die normal weiter jetzt kommt
eben zu diesem konsequenzen dieser
während die hetero docs ist also nicht
so ganz auf die linie der damaligen
religion passt hat man kann nicht ohne
schrecken an die konsequenzen der
folgenden lehre denken die seele des
menschen die seele der tiere
unterscheiden sich nicht substanziell
sind von der selben art die eine wirkung
mehr einsichten als die andere
aber das sind nur aktie den teller
persönliche vorteile die von einer
willkürlichen einrichtung des gehirns
abhängen
diese lehre ergibt sich zwangsläufig
unvermeidlicherweise aus dem was in den
schulen über die erkenntnis der tiere
gelehrt wird
wenn die seele der tiere materiell
unsterblich sind zur folgt aus dass die
seele des menschen es auch sinn wenn die
seele der menschen eine geistige
unsterbliche substanz ist so ist dies
jede hat ihre dass auch entsetzliche
folgerungen gleichgültig in welcher
seite man sich zu wenden
denn wenn man um die unsterblichkeit der
seele zu vermeiden annimmt dass die
seele des menschen mit dem körper stirbt
er stürzt man die lehre von einem
anderen leben um und begräbt die
fundamente der religion
wenn man um unserer seele das
vorrichtung sterblichkeit zu erhalten
das selber auf die tiere diese tiere
ausdehnt welche abgründe werden in die
abgründe werden wir dann stürzen was
werden der mit so vielen unsterblichen
seele machen das auch für sie einfacher
diesen eine höhle geben werden sie aus
einem körper in einen anderen wandern
werden sie in dem maße vernichtet wie
die tiere sterben wird gott unaufhörlich
eine unendliche menge geiste erschaffen
um sie so bald darauf ins nicht
zu stürzen wie viele insekten gibt es
die nur wenige tage leben
wir wollen uns nicht einbilden dass es
ausreicht zählen für die tiere zu
schaffen die wir kennen
diejenigen von dem wir nicht kennen sind
noch weit größeren zahlen
das mikroskop listen tausende davon
einem wassertropfen entdecken und wir
würden weit mehr darin entdecken wir
vollkommen unrealistisch koppl hätten
und man sagen nicht die insekten seinen
maschinen gegen descartes wenn man
erklärt durch diese lehre er die
handlungen von hunden als sie von
ameisen bienen vielleicht haben die
nicht sichtbaren tiere mehr geissen mehr
vernunft als die größten wir wollen
jetzt die vergeblichen bemühungen
betrachten welche die schule philosophen
angesprochen so viel angestellt hat um
einen spezifischen unterschied zwischen
tiert menschenseele festzusetzen
als er sagt jetzt wie man es dreht und
wendet so lange man annimmt dass tiere
ist eine seele haben und das ist für ihn
unabweisbar müssen wir eigentlich dieser
seele wenn wir sie nicht immer wenn wir
sie nicht materiell denken wollen weil
man damit eben die unsterblichkeit der
menschlichen seele verlieren würden
dieselben potenziellen fähigkeiten zu
sprechen wie der menschlichen zellen so
das will ich jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen zur diskussion stellen was
halten sie jetzt von diesem argument
leuchtet das ihnen ein kann man
vielleicht descartes doch ein bisschen
verteidigen
gut genau also wenn jetzt alle zählen
danach im paradies oder einen anderen
ort wären müssen ständig neue seelen
geschaffen werden
ökonomischer ein prinzip der unter
logischen sparsamkeit
das
die er schon bekommen
jahre brauchen sich schon ich weiss
nicht wie vielen jahren
richtig hier erscheint wohl alle
konsequenzen bis ins letzte sich
ausdenken zu wollen
nur in alle richtungen bis zum letzten
extrem er legt sich ja nicht direkt fest
er sagt nur nehmen wir das annehmen dann
haben wir dieses problem wie man das
gegenteil annehmen dann ergibt sich
dieses problem irgendwie ist immer
schwierig
genau
gut gut richtig ja das wird zum beispiel
mögliche kritikpunkte erscheint ja alles
was ich irgendwie was saal ganz pauschal
als organismus beschreiben lässt
als sie das
die pflanzen werden auch nicht behandelt
richtig richtig genau also das
historische modell kann man sich fragen
ist es nur dass hier was seelisch ist
sitzen damit ernährung aus wenn jetzt
sagt zur kleinste ich weiß nicht mit
groben oder was auch immer bakterien die
sich in einem wassertropfen finden wenn
das auch seelische wesen sind dann ist
doch der schritt nicht weit sagen dass
auch pflanzen im seele haben
verstöße sind
ja wer würde ja sagen der einzeller hat
auch eine seele aber hat eben nicht die
richtigen organe um die seele so
auszubilden dass sie zu solchen gedanken
der lage ist wie aristoteles zum
beispiel der einzeller wäre eben sehr
sehr beschränkt von seinen organen nach
bald schon da hätte auch so lange erlebt
so lange tier ist wenn man als ein
zeichen dass hat die kommilitonen ja
gerade so ein bisschen problematisiert
ob man bakterien als tiere bezeichnen
kann
sonst sind so zwischenformen zwischen
pflanzen ich bin jetzt kein biologe aber
es scheint ja so nicht ganz klar ein
tier zu sein ein bakterium
obwohl es hat bestimmte eigenschaften
hat reproduktion deshalb produziert sich
dna und ganz klar aber es ist irgendwie
ja nicht so ein typischer organismus wie
wir ihnen bei höher entwickelten tieren
kennen also da wäre es für die frage wie
wir sie zu diesem grenzbereich aus und
vor allem wie sieht's mit pflanzen aus
sind pflanzen nur seelen die extremst
körperlich begrenzt sind weil sie keine
wahrnehmung keine bewegung haben
aristoteles sagt pflanzen haben auch
eine seele die ernährung die näher seele
pflanzen ernähren sich sie sind
seelische wesen
wie sieht es damit aus diese frage
behandelt jetzt nicht und stimmen sie
dem zu das würden sie auch sagen dass
also woran hängt denn jetzt dieses
argument von bell an welchem an welcher
überzeugung hängt dieses argument jetzt
wie könnte man da jetzt mit einem strich
mit einem einer infragestellung das
fundament oder den füßen wegziehen
was ist die vermisste was ist die
prämisse und der alles hängt ja haben
sie eine idee
hier in diesen märkten
ja schon das sicherlich wenn er sagt
jetzt hier diesem zitat die these ist
also eine substanz die denkt sie ist
folglich das denken sie überhaupt fähig
sie kann also alle arten von gedanken
empfangen
man müsste jetzt wie mir scheint
bestreiten dass die tierische ziele also
bale sagt er praktisch es ist gar nicht
legitim die seele in verschiedene arten
zu unterteilen weil es nur die
modifikation oder rahmenbedingung sind
in denen dieses ziel existiert also es
ist praktisch so es sei jetzt die seele
eines beliebigen lebewesens und der
mensch den ich jetzt mit ihm ab kürze
der wäre praktisch dass die die seele im
modus des mensch ein tier wäre die seele
im modus unter dem exponenten des tieres
das ist so wird mensch und tier
vorgestellt seele im modus des menschen
oder in den körper des menschen mit den
menschlichen organen und die seele des
tieres 100 den spezifischen organischen
bedingungen des tieres
diese ist eigentlich bin ich denke
durchaus ja also es geben die richtung
also bei die karte ist er unsterblich
das ist bei bell jetzt auch noch es ist
halt die sicht auf die tiere die sich
völlig bei beiden unterscheidet also das
ist menschenseele zähle unter den
bedingungen der menschen organe ziel und
mit dem getier stocker
aber es ist immer dieselbe seele also es
keine seele arten unterseen typen einmal
seele immer zähle nur der kontext in dem
sich die selbe findet ich glaube man
kann aber dieses argument so angreifen
dass man sagt im wie descartes tiere
denken nicht tiere denken nicht und
deswegen haben sie auch keine seele so
könnte man es versuchen zu machen dass
man tiere denken nicht ihre sind
instinktiv gewunden hat das ganze
argument scheint wenn ich es riecht sie
davon abzuhängen dass tiere denken wenn
sie mal denken dann könnten sie
prinzipiell alles denken
unter den richtigen bedingungen man
müsste jetzt suchen zu argumentieren
dass tiere nicht denken dass das was im
kopf der tiere vorgeht
irgendwie ja irgendwas ist was eben
nicht denken ist irgendwelche
determinismus irgend welche mechanismen
dieser atmen
das war jetzt pb und jetzt haben sie
noch fahren sehr originelle these
natürlich sehr originell wenn sie jetzt
keine fragen mit zu viel haben dann ich
habe es auch in der zusammenfassung
recht ausführlich glaube ich dargestellt
kann ich kann in der heutigen
zusammenfassung ein bisschen genauer
darstellen
jetzt gehen wir über zu david hume und
er hat einen ganz kurzen abschnitt über
die vernunft der tiere und wie ich
vorhin an die tafel geschrieben hatte
müssen sie sich da eben bewusst sein
dass nach der wie die jugend die
vernunft nichts höheres ist wie jetzt
bei die karte kein höheres
erkenntnisvermögen sondern eine sklavin
der effekte also nur instrumentelle
vernunft die vernunft ist dazu da
unseren sinnen wahrnehmen wir unseren
bedürfnissen gerecht zu werden als er es
kommt die bedürfnisse körperlicher art
und dann springt die vernunft ein
das ist diese das bedeutet die rede von
der vernunft als klar winter effekte
und jetzt haben wir mal weiter mit david
hume er sagt wir sind uns bewusst dass
wir wenn wir unseren zwecken die mittel
anpassen von vernunft und absicht
geleitet werden
das wenig blinder zufällig die handlung
von bringen die auf selbsterhaltung
herbeiführung von lustgefühl und abwehr
der unlust abziehen himmel und andere
geschöpfe in millionen von beispiel
gleich handlungen ausführen und dabei
die gleiche zwecke verfolgen sehen
weswegen wir uns alle ihre prinzipien
der vernunft wahrscheinlichkeit
erkenntnis unwiderstehlich hierbei an
das vorhandensein einer gleichen sache
zu glauben es ist meiner meinung nach
nutzlos dieses argument durch aufzählung
von einzel tatsachen zu beleuchten die
geringste aufmerksamkeit wird uns mehr
beispiele als erforderlich sind an die
hand geben
die ähnlichkeit die zwischen den
handlungen der tiere und in der menschen
in der bezeichneten hinsicht besteht ist
eine so vollkommen dass uns die erste
beste handlung eines beliebigen tieres
die wir herausgreifen mögen einen
unbestreitbaren beleg für unsere
behauptung an die hand gibt
ja also
es geht also hier wie bei aristoteles
fast schon obwohl hier um kein adeliger
ist immer um zwecke und mittel also das
ganze leben ist nach dekade nach jüngste
kreation ahl verfasst
und was sind diese zwecke die sind
selbst der haltung herbeiführung von
lust gefühlen und abwehr um ist das ist
nach jugend der antrieb alles lebens
alles leben ist so eingerichtet dass es
diesen bedingungen gerecht wird
um eben diese ziele zu erreichen also
lust zu maximieren unlust zu vermeiden
und sich selbst zu halten brauchen wir
hilfsmittel brauchen den instrument und
dieses instrument was uns dazu verhilft
es und so in der welt zurechtzufinden
dass eben diese punkte hier erreicht
werden das ist die vernunft
also sagt offensichtlich alles lebendig
oder zumindest irische ist so
ausgerichtet dass diesen zielen folgt
und weil es diesen zu ihren zielen folgt
muss es auch eine form von rationalität
haben die diese ziele erreichen kann
sagt weiter die vorgetragene anschaue
ist ebenso nützlich wie sie einleuchtend
ist sie gibt uns eine art von prüfstand
an dem wir jede theorie die innerhalb
dieses gebietes der philosophie
aufgestellt werden mag prüfen können
aus der ähnlichkeit der äußeren handlung
der tiere und derjenigen die wir selbst
ausführen schließen wir dass auch ihre
inneren handlung in unseren bereichen
und wenn wir nach demselben prinzip noch
einen schritt weiter gehen sehen wir uns
genötigt zu schließen dass da ihre
inneren handlungen den unsrigen gleichen
die ursachen aus den beiden springen
gleichfalls übereinstimmen müssen
und also irgendeine hypothese
aufgestellt wird die zur erklärung einer
den menschen und tieren gemeinsam
geistigen tätigkeit dient so also müssen
wir zusehen ob diese hypothese auf beide
tiere und die menschen in gleicher weise
anwendbar ist jede richtige prothese
wird diese prüfung bestehen
starke zu behaupten ist ebenso jede
falsche an ihr zuschanden werden wird
wie geht er jetzt hier vor wie
schlimmsten erschließt jetzt ja
irgendwie auch weglassen können sie mir
noch mal sagen wir jetzt hier schließt
von was schließt er auf was
etwas beginnt er
äußere handlung genau
ja
und verschließen dann von inneren
handlungen noch genau die ursachen aus
den beiden springen
und mir scheint dass hier bei diesen
ursachen dass hier dann die vernunft
liegt hier scheint die gemeinsamkeit zu
sein der letzte grund dieser ähnlichen
handlungen innere handlung ist auch
spannend fand ich sehr interessant dass
jugend so was wie immer behandlung
überhaupt kennt man könnte sagen innere
handlungen gibt es nicht weil handlung
immer etwas mit wirklichkeit zu tun hat
handlung ist immer bewirken
also richtig fast schon mechanisch
vorgestellt und das war sie in unserem
kopf vorgeht das ist natürlich durchaus
irgendwas was etwas bewegt zum beispiel
kann ein wunsch etwas anderes bewirken
also ein wunsch kann auch bewirken dass
ich etwas tue also dass mentales kann es
etwas größeren führen und ich kann
natürlich auch selbst meinen willen
bestimmen ich kann wenn ich willens frei
bin mich zu meinen inneren bedürfnissen
verhalten innerlich kann ich mich zu mir
selbst verhalten ich kann zum beispiel
sagen will ich jetzt wirklich meinem
bedürfnis nach essen folgen
oder will ich es nicht will ich jetzt
essen oder nicht
ich habe jetzt in mit dem das bedürfnis
nach etwas zu essen
jetzt kann ich sagen ich möchte es nicht
dann sorge ich will endlich dafür dass
mein bedürfnis nach nahrung nicht mehr
weiter berücksichtigt wird und so was
dass man sagt die ich widerstehe einer
inneren tendenz aus bestimmten gründen
das wäre eine innere handlung
ich habe dafür gesorgt dass mein
hungergefühl zwar nicht jetzt
ausgebildet aber dass es mich nicht mehr
weiter antreibt ich blende es aus das
ist eine innere handlung könnte man
sagen manche bestreiten dass manche
sagen innere handlung gibt es nicht kann
es nicht geben
weil man kann sich ja dann immer fragen
bei der inneren handlung
wer ist da eigentlich das objekt dieser
inneren handlungen gewinnen
das objekt der inneren handlung ist
nicht so greifbar das objekt der äußeren
handlung ist greifbar das ist unser
organismus unser körper organisiert
lebendiges da gibt es verschiedene
probleme die mit dieser inneren handlung
zusammenhängen aber es scheint
offensichtlich in der behandlung für
möglich zu halten als in den tieren geht
irgendetwas vor
und das was in ihnen vorgeht in den kopf
dass es irgendwie rational strukturiert
der gewöhnliche fehler der theorien
welche die philosophen zur erklärung der
tätigkeiten des geistes aufgestellt
haben besteht darin dass sie eine
kompliziertheit und subtilität des
vorstellen voraussetzen die nicht nur
die geistige fähigkeit der tiere
übersteigt sondern schon die der kinder
und des gemeinen volkes innerhalb
unserer eigenen spezies obgleich diese
doch derselben gefühlsregungen und
affekte fähig sind die leute mit dem
ausgebildeten geist und verstand in
solche subtilitäten voraussetzt liefert
damit ein deutlicher beweis von der
unrichtigkeit seine lehre sowie es
umgekehrt für die richtigkeit einer
theorie spricht wenn sie einfache
voraussetzung macht unterziehen also
unsere theorie betreffend die natur des
verstandes dieser entscheidenden probe
das heißt wir zu ob sich aus derselben
die schlussfolgerung der tiere in
gleicher weise erklären wie die der
menschen
wo jetzt sagte hier also die tiere haben
auch schlussfolgerungen
wir hatten das letzte mal ein text
abschnitt von keppel gelesen
sie nennen sie es noch wo es um so eine
art von konditionierung ging
wir hatten dieses beispiel von bell als
konditionierung beschrieben
ja wenn adam bien hat das war glaube ich
das war glaube ich so der hund hat
fleisch gefressen und immer wenn er das
getan hatte dann hat ihn der herr
gezüchtigt glaube ich so war das
beispiel und deswegen hat der hund immer
in der anwesenheit des herrn nicht das
fleisch gefressen
weil er offensichtlich so wählt daraus
geschlossen hatte das wiener fleisch
frisst er vom halter abgestraft wird
jetzt haben wir uns gefragt ist es
wirklich eine schlussfolgerung
also wenn ich etwas mache wenn ich da
mache dann voll b kann man das so
richtig beschreiben
das war die frage und dagegen hatten
sich stimmen gewendet die gesagt hat
nein das ist keine schluss folgen der
verfolgung sollen das ist ein input
output schema das ist er seine starre
notwendigkeit das ist eine
konditionierung da ist keine
nationalität überhaupt dabei das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen erinnerung aber
es ist jetzt nicht eigentlich kognitive
leistung
gut dass wir ein guter punkt genau also
die frage ist denn hier
ob wir ich habe es in der
zusammenfassung sowie dargestellt zwar
vielleicht nicht ganz präzise dass der
hund erster überhaupt erkennen muss
opfer vorliegt
er muss es ja auch entscheiden ob fall
vorliegt auf den dann wie folgt in
matisse sagen ist glaube ich auch noch
gut er wird ja wird ja noch eine
alternative haben c usw
und er fragt den c oder den adern bhc
ich auch machen und bei c vielleicht
denn die oder so das heißt er ist er
verhält sich dagegen über oder auch noch
eine andere option vielleicht dann
vergleicht er jetzt miteinander
oder er würde die kondition über die
kondition also oder er wird eben sagen
ich nehme das in kauf das wäre die frage
er sagt er sagt ja nicht aber er würde
vielleicht deswegen sein dass jetzt das
geringere übel lieber bekomme ich ein
paar schläge als das jetzt verhungert
wäre die fahrer genau das wollte müsste
immer schauen finden also
abwägungsprozesses stadtführung sagt
ganz klar der finden abwägungsprozess
statt und hier und da sagte er muss man
muss eine einfache theorie machen und
keine subtilitäten also da nicht zuviel
geistigkeit ansätzen eine ganz einfache
vernunft reicht sagte weiter hierbei
müssen wir einen unterschied machen
zwischen denjenigen handlung der tiere
die alltäglicher natur sind und über die
fähigkeiten die waren ihnen jederzeit
beobachten dich hinaus zu gehen scheinen
und die ihnen beim spielen eines
außergewöhnlichen schaffens wie ihn
tiere bis verein da an den tag legen wo
es sich um ihre eigene haltung und die
fortpflanzung ihrer art handelt ein hund
der voller abgründe vermeidet fremde
schuld und sanieren liebkost liefert uns
beispiel die verhandlungen der erste rat
der vogel der mit 2.000
ausserordentlicher sorgfalt und behutsam
karl den ort und das material zum bau
seines nestes auswählt und dann in der
dazu günstigen der arbeitszeit genauso
lang als erforderlich ist mit aller
vorsicht wie sieht für einen chemiker
bei den feinsten versuch anwenden könnte
seine eier bebrütet
er gibt uns ein lebendiges beispiel für
die zeit der tierische handlung
haben tiere einen außergewöhnlichen
scharfsinn wie david hughes hat
ist der nestbau eines vogels wirklich
ein zeichen von außergewöhnlichem scharf
sind ja gute punkt also sie haben recht
es irgendwie einprogrammiert ist hier
der vogel muss zu einer bestimmten
jahreszeit dessen ist bauen dass der
kann es garnicht nicht mehr kann es
garnicht nicht bauen wollen er muss es
bauen und man würde manchmal sagen
schreib sinnlichkeit hat irgendwas mit
freiheit zu tun
scharf sind ist jetzt nicht
notwendigerweise der den abend in
bestimmten situationen angelegt sein
scharfsinn ist steht zur disposition
desjenigen der schafik ist ein
scharfsinniger mathematiker muss das
nicht dna mäßig tun
schaut es nicht so sein sondern kann es
machen oder auch nicht er kann
schachspieler darin schaff's nicht sein
oder auch nicht ein vogel muss halt das
nest bauen
worin meinen sie liegt dann aber sehr
scharf sind im bauen des nests das
scheint schon davor zu schweben an
scharfsinn hcd was wie ein schaf sind
braucht der vogel um das nest zu bauen
worin besteht dass schaafs in ganzen
idee
es hatte sich da jemand genannt
so viel nach
[Musik]
genau ich habe dann ist eine grenze für
die hilfen hat mit der biologin gemacht
und ich dachte die vögel müssen die
nester warum dieses keineswegs los und
eine genaue auswahl werden
wie viele begleitete überhaupt vorhanden
sind also auch davon überleben damit
innerhalb zumindest von
okay wir haben so ein bisschen diese
spannung einerseits ganz klar dass eine
hohe kunst ist eine fertigkeit der tiere
also eines das es hoch artifiziell auch
bienen bienenwaben sind ja ganz
geometrisch präzise perfekt
ich glaube bei bienen sieht man es noch
deutlicher das problem dass die da
irgendwie ein programm ab zu spielen
scheinen dieses programm selbst könnte
man jetzt sagen mit einem kritiker
dieser theorie
das programm das ist schaust du nicht
aber nicht die individuen dies abspielen
könnte man sagen
man könnte jetzt mit ich will jetzt
einfach hingegen bringe die diskussion
ob sie können gerne darauf gegeben er
könne sagen wie gut bin ich jetzt hier
in computer bestimmte software drauf
spieler auf den computer die besonders
intelligent gemacht ist dann rechnet der
computer mir eben tolle sachen aus wenn
ich halt nicht so eine tolle software
drauf spiele dann halt nicht das ist
nicht der computer der scharfsinnige ist
sondern die software vergleichbar mit
der dna auf die sich an gespielt hat
das könnte mir jetzt zu sagen ja
gut gut
gut das ist ein guter punkt das ist ein
guter punkt genau das ist ein guter
punkt der sagt also die äußerlichen
handlung sind gleich wesentlich gleich
das kann man natürlich jetzt eine frage
stimmen haben sagt es sind gleich alles
es zweckmäßig eingerichtet der mensch
baut sich halt häuser der mensch will
halt auch dass es ihm gut geht will
nicht hungern und so also liegen
die tiere haben ähnliche äußere handlung
also liegen die selbe inneren handlung
zugrunde die wir jetzt nicht sehen
können wir keine inneren der handlungen
nicht sehen wir können nur anschließen
und also muss auch die ursache nämlich
die vernunft dieselbe sein
was könnte man jetzt darauf wieder
reagieren auf diese these dass die
äußere handlung dieselben sind
gibt es äußere handlung des menschen die
nicht oder die quali hat die von den
äußeren handlungen von tieren
verschieden sind
mit der zunge
gut haben sie ein beispiel haben zum
beispiel haben sie beispiele was es sein
könnte so eine handlung gegen den
sticker ja genau monogamie oder
wenigsten oder sowas ja
was ist das hat ja genau genau machen
tiere diät hier nicht oder machen sie es
nie wenn die was finden dann leben sie
es zu sichern
für den fall dass es mal schlechtere
umstände gibt mir ja ich glaube auch
dass eine diät durchaus ein zeichen von
einer handlung ist die ihr auch so was
von willensfreiheit stehe schließen
lässt eine diät heißt doch nichts
anderes als ich habe ihn mir gewisse
bedürfnisse nach essen aber ich verhalte
mich innerlich in der behandlung ich
verhalte mich innerlich noch mal zu mir
selbst
also man könnte das in frage stellen ob
es ob es auch wirklich alle äußeren
handlungen selben sind mit ihren jungs
scheint dann recht begrenzten fokus zu
haben erscheint zu sagen gut der mensch
möchte nicht hungern der mensch möchte
leid vermeiden
der mensch möchte sich selbst erhalten
und das ist alles das sind die drei
faktoren die die samt gesamten cas und
handlungen des menschen bedingt dann
würde ich ihn zu filmen ja wie ist es
mit rom houben bekannt werden wollen
tiere bekannt werden ist ruhm dasselbe
wie selbsterhaltung dies ist nicht ein
menschliches zeichen eickel zu sein
eitel sind tiere eitel sind tiere
narzisstisch sind tiere egoistisch
es war die frage genau das war die frage
genau wenn man selbsterhaltung weit
genug fast ja aber dass die frage gelte
also ich glaube
dazu zählt auch optisch soll ich machen
scheint aber sonst sind sie
fr
über
sie sehen wir sind jetzt schon wieder
bei ganz konkreten beispiel das ist auch
gut und dann ist immer die frage ja was
sagt es die biologie dazu wie ist es mit
delfinen da sind wir dann alle nicht
mehr so kompetenz erhöhen wir nicht
belogen sind das müssen aber auch gar
nicht entscheiden dass darauf kommt es
ja letztendlich in der philosophie
anzusehen ist jedenfalls so was wir hier
nur leisten können und es sollten ist
einfach die verschiedenen möglichkeiten
uns zu überlegen wie könnte man dieses
argument von juni infrage stellen
offensichtlich in dem hier irgendwo
ansätzen an seiner prämisse das ist
unsere tätigkeit und dann können wir
schauen gibt es jetzt in der biologie
gibt es im konkreten wissenschaften
beispiel die dafür sprechen dagegen
das ist ein konkret angewandt aber die
eigentliche philosophische arbeit
scheint mir doch die zu sein wenn man zu
fragen wo ist ein einfallstor für kritik
wenn wir mal abzubilden ohne jetzt seine
experte biologe biologischen zeit zu
müssen genau also wie gesagt immer
abwägen so ein bisschen was spricht
dafür wie sie es jetzt gesagt haben dass
das tier scharfsinnig ist wie könnte man
das kritisieren das ist scharfsinnig ist
natürlich muss man sich fragen was ist
überhaupt scharf sind also die hohen
kunstfertigkeit sie sicherlich aber ist
es wirklich kunstfertigkeit die man sich
erworben hat denken sie mal einen
bedeutenden malern bedeutende malerin
die ist ja der ist ja nicht die maler
kunst in die wiege gelegt worden sondern
eine gute malerin hat sich das ganz
langwierig arbeiten müssen sie hat
vielleicht eine begabung gehabt aber sie
herz nicht von anfang an können und sie
hat auch nicht einfach so von natur aus
hinbekommen sonderbar führung notwendig
und die frage ist es bei tieren auch so
dass tiere sowie üben müssen
im netz zu bauen ich glaube nicht dass
tiere da erstmal für üben und dann
irgendwann wenn sie geschlechtsreif sind
dann irgendwelche welt ihre nester bauen
sind die können das halt einfach ich bin
kein biologe es scheint so zu sein
sie würden das sagen dass etwas was so
codiert ist nichts mit schafft dass ich
das nicht mit charts sind verträgt
würden sie sagen
hat die einfach aus irgendwelchen
schnell heraus absolut nichts zum
nächsten gefunden habe das ganze absolut
nichts probe sich zuletzt sogar ein
also kann diese überhaupt beurteilen wie
sich am verhalten würden
also sie meinen dass vielleicht dann
unter bestimmten umständen der vogel
kreativ wird oder dass er dann
verhungert oder so dass er dann
verhungern würde und das wäre einfach
song testfall dafür zu sagen es ist halt
doch so ein programmierter infrastruktur
den ihm programmierte sind die nichts
mit kunstfertigkeit zu tun hat
ich meine wir haben jetzt aber doch
schon das beispiel dieser raben und
krähen gehabt die sich instrument gebaut
haben also die raben und krähen sind
offensichtlich so ein instrument angeht
bei dem man zeigen kann dass da die
kunstfertigkeit im gewissen karte halpin
vorhanden ist oder
[Musik]
wir haben ja keinen
genau man muss unterscheiden von fall zu
fall und raben und krähen sind die uns
mittels intelligentesten bekanntesten
tiere der viele sind auch noch sehr
intelligent sie hatten sie noch gemeldet
auswählen gelb wie ich es nehme ich
jetzt genau genau hat die zupfen das
dann raus und es dann raus wichtig genau
die müssen ja offensichtlich auch mit
neuen materialien die nicht in ihrem
genetischen code irgendwie drin sind man
könnte jetzt sagen wegen welche wurzeln
oder irgendwelche blätter sind im
genetischen code drin im evolutionär wir
jetzt aber so kunstfasern oder so hat
die können im genetischen code nicht
drin sein oder kokosfasern die in einem
anderen leben
genau dieser anderen geographischen
situationen springen dann muss ja
offensichtlich ist ihr schon sich
überlegen in einer gewissen form wäre
das ein möglicher fall damit könnte ich
das damit machen fällt das unter diesen
begriff und da müsste mit dem tier so
eine gewisse form von urteilskraft zu
sprechen ist eine falle erkennung
hätte
jetzt
man könnte jetzt sagen das ist so ein
genetisch programmiert ist eine
genetisch programmiert die
mustererkennung wie wäre es damit wenn
man sagt das tier ist determiniert
darauf dass es halt alle dinge in der
welt gegen einem bestimmten muster
entsprechen nutzt um damit etwas zu
bauen wäre das dann auch noch scharf
sind wenn es eine programmierte
mustererkennung wäre
sie haben recht die anwendung des muss
das ist ja auch eine leistung also das
eine ist das muster in sich zu haben zu
wissen was ich tun muss genau also soll
man das muster ist ja immer so eine
gattung überbegriff und welche konkreten
orten fallen dann unter dieses muster
also das ist die urteilskraft dann auch
wieder sie haben ein recht also selbst
wenn ich das muster habe muss ich immer
noch entscheiden ob jetzt ein bestimmtes
ding und das muster fällt könnte man
sagen das müsst ihr automatisch gehen da
bin jetzt eben auch nicht genug fachmann
uns zu erklären sie sehen welche
probleme sicherstellen man könnte sagen
er ist mit mit seinem muster ist nur
eine bestimmte form von freiheit gegeben
weil die urteilskraft entscheiden muss
entspricht dieses ding denn die muster
es muss ja immer noch ein minimales
urteil gefällt werden
ok service oder sowas kontroversen
geführt
also bei krähen bestimmt bei krähen geht
es mit sicherheit genau genommen müsste
sich jetzt konkrete beispiele legen
es ist schon erstaunlich wie sich tiere
eben nischen suchen auch in der
menschlichen lebenswelt wo dann tiere
ihre nester bauen wo man nie drauf kämen
und sich wundert warum ist es da ein
tier trinken oder ein vogel oder auch
insekten war vielleicht nicht aber man
sieht dass das land hier in diesem fall
steckt drin ist was eigentlich für das
ganz anders gedacht waren wenn wir so
eine klimaanlage das dann tier in der
klimaanlage jetzt irgendwie brütet so
normal ist in der klimaanlage keine
ahnung aber ob das dann auch kreatives
oder ob da nicht ist sie einfach den
besten weg gefunden hat den geringsten
widerstands gegangen
viele denken wo es einfach für das tier
ökonomischen sozusagen für den körper
nicht mehr sinnvoll ist wird sich immer
noch auf die idee das netz pause zu
verschaffen sondern ist jetzt eigentlich
zielführende aber effizienter wäre eine
völlig andere alternative zu suchen
also ich weiß dass ich wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass ein vogel der einfach
absolut nichts zum nest bauen findet und
kein wort und nichts dass er einen platz
findet wo er keinen es okay
wenn der staat mit interessen
nat
[Musik]
ja als sie sehen also man muss immer
dass sich mögliche beispiel überlegen
das ist die philosophie also welcher
fall müsste eintreten um das entscheiden
zu können
das ist glaube ich die art und weise wie
wir als philosophen für soviel kompetent
über die frage sprechen können optieren
geist haben welche bedingungen müssen
erfüllt sein welche modelle gebe es um
da entscheiden zu können das ist unsere
ebene wo wir uns befinden
kein tier und sie würden dann sagen beim
menschen ist es so dass der mensch
selbst etwas tut wenn er keinen
unmittelbaren reiz hat als idealen sie
meinen als ideale zum beispiel religiöse
motive die jetzt nicht unmittelbaren und
reizt bieten so was ideale oder
philosophie machen dass du hast prüfen
genau philosophie
jahrhundert
mehr war war ihr sehr unglücklicher als
philosophen
eine freundin von mir sie haben einen
wagen der seit jahren immer das gleiche
überhaupt gar kein projekt sondern ist
kupfer habe ihn abdeckung und seit
jahren unter depressionen
die meister steigen trafen mann
erscheint ihm einen spaß zu machen das
ist zwar kein konkretes mit der
annähernd vorstellen können dass er
spielsüchtig ja ich habe gesehen machbar
aus
da war ich jeden und da ist
hat sich das vergnügen geworden
also doch scharfsinnig die tiere die
krähen zumindest
sagt was kreativ ist ja bei haben
scheint es mir sehr plausibel zu sein ja
die fliegen
ja aber es war eben keine unmittelbare
ganz konkreter zweck mehr der die tiere
auch so eine bahn lenken würde und dann
wäre das verhalten eben die menschlichen
sehr ähnlich wenn wir spielen haben wir
dann hat das macht es uns auch los
natürlich spaß aber jetzt nicht ganz
konkret wie jetzt hier ist ein anreiz
oder so und im spielen können wir ganz
verschiedenen spielen wir können runter
rutschen wir können noch aufsteigen wir
können was fallen lassen
das scheint mir ein zu leuchten dieses
beispiel natürlich wieder bei haben und
besonderen tieren müsste man experimente
machen genau also überzahlspiel könnte
man auch so eine form von freiheit oder
schaf sinnlichkeit testen sagte weiter
was die handlung der ersten art
anbelangt so behaupte ich dass sie aus
eine überlegung hervorgehen die nicht
nur in sich nicht verschiedene ist von
derjenigen die der menschlichen natur zu
tage tritt sondern auch auf keinen
anderen voraus zu berufen zunächst ist
auch bei tieren als voraussetzung für
ihre urteile ein dem gedächtnis oder den
sinn unmittelbar gegebene eindruck
erforderlich den hund lässt der ton der
stimme seines herrn auf dessen zorn
schließen und seine bestrafung für
aussehen
aufgrund einer bestimmten erfindung
seines geruchssinns urteilt er
dass das wild nicht mehr sehr weiteren
ihm entfernt sein ja ist das jetzt ein
urteil das ist die ganz spannende frage
wie sehen sie ist verteilt ein hund ganz
schwierig wir sind jetzt mitten in den
schwierigsten problem der philosophie
des geistes urteil hat er immer eine
professionelle struktur ein urteil kann
immer sofort werden dass mit diesem das
hatte der hund das muss eine das
struktur haben erkennen erkennen dass
das reh nahe ist usw
dass das real ist
rückhalt urteilt der hunde durch einen
geruchssinn hat haben gerüche eine
proportionale struktur ist eine
spannende frage kann in einem geruch an
eine botschaft enthalten sein die sich
auf diese das form bringen ist
[Applaus]
ja das wäre ein systemisches problem
aber ich denke schon dass wir doch
fordern dürfen das dass es sich beim
teilen genau so verhält wie bei uns alle
urteilen ist wo teile müssen wir alle
gleich seien von der art her sonst wäre
es keine urteile glaube ich eigentlich
meine ich kenne es von mir auch in
manchen situation wenn ich mich in einer
belebten gegend befindet straßenverkehr
dann habe ich schon oft den eindruck
gehabt ich wäre jetzt also ganz schnell
ein urteil wie ich ja weg für mich jetzt
der beste ist und ich sehe jetzt drei
oder vier mögliche hindernisse voraus
auf einen schlag und ich komme zu dem
ergebnis da laufe ich jetzt lang
es ist auch solar musste erkennung die
so ganz spontan eintritt und die für
mich aber irgendwie ich schon habe ich
mir oft gedanken gemacht schon so eine
art urteil bedeutet ich bin jetzt
gefestigt in dieser entscheidung hier
entlang zu gehen
ich gehe es hier lang weil das ist die
beste möglichkeit weil hier dieses
internet kommen und und das passieren
könnte
also ich erkenne oder ich nehme situativ
war das
habe ich manchmal bei mir den eindruck
kennt jeder sicherlich von ihnen auch
aber jetzt bei einem tier hat das
wirklich gefällt dass sein urteil
zum beispiel schon
auf der straße
mit
mehr
nicht wir gewusst
da haben zuletzt sehr gut
es ist der geruch
ja ja die nase eine was ist dieser
geruch so verfasst dass er ein urteil
enthält ist komisch weil ich meine wir
riechen ja auch vieles was ein hund
riecht dann kommen ja zu anderen
urteilen oder gar nicht zu urteilen
also es ist es kann sein dass in
gewissen die duftstoffen in gewissen
vorkommnissen ein hund mehr information
rauszieht als wir sie kennen spruch ich
kann den nicht riechen ich kann die
nicht riecht das kennen sie alle
aber die frage ist ob es sich bei ihnen
bewusst abspielt wenn sie jemand nicht
riechen können und ob sie dann urteilen
film oder ob sie nicht hinterher
rationalisieren sein
ja das ist der grund warum ich mit
dieser person nicht so gut kann wenn
nichts genau bedenken ich kann sie nicht
riechen oder ob sie das jetzt in der
situation konkret sagen aha geruch okay
daraus folgt irgendwie passen nicht
zueinander und irgendwie sowas eben ja
aber ist das bewusst im sinne eines
urteils glaube eher unbewusst
neben wendeten die leicht und da
vielleicht angeschlagen
dass sich der sohn
also was mir jetzt ein leuchten würde
wäre wenn man sagt der hund oder
bestimmte tiere können eben aufgrund
ihres besonders ausgeprägten riechorgan
besonders viele informationen aus
duftstoffe ziehen die uns so nicht zur
verfügung stehen und dieses mehr an
information was tiere aus diesen zins
tat ziehen dieses meer könnte dafür
ausreichend seien
zu seinem urteil zu gelangen das würde
mir einleuchten dass man sagt der hund
der zieht so viel information aus dem
duftstoff heraus so viele faktoren die
man so präsent sind und die für ihn so
klar vor augen stehen dass es zu dem
urteil kommt während wir auf basis von
gerüchen eigentlich so wenige
informationen bekommen wir es wurde
gesagt es mag bei der partnerwahl eine
rolle spielen oder evolutionär bedingt
sein usw
pheromone was nicht alles gibt ja aber
die sind uns jedenfalls nicht bewusst
und tieren könnte das bewusstsein könnt
ihr sein weil sie einfach diese
information so hochgradig aufgelöst im
bewusstsein haben da sind ist eine art
urteil kommen das würde mir also einen
aufgrund dieser informationsdichte die
durch die sensibilität die höhere
sensibilität des tierischen wahrnehmung
des organs gegeben ist einfach ein
urteil gefällt werden könnte
laut dem jüngst ex wenn wir ihn auch
freunde des kann mit der waffe und wenn
ich mich jetzt fragen ob ich mir selber
zum schreiben kam dass ich erkenne dass
ein kuchen auf dem tisch steht man nicht
irgendwie sehen kann und ein urteil
darüber fällen kuchen und den will ich
mir nicht nur ein sondern da steht
wirklich einer
wir haben soll dann also warum kann man
das mich dann auch über fragen auf den
grund dass man sagt der genutzt hat
somit erkennen
die frage ist eben die ob um ein urteil
fällen zu können wir nicht begriffs
vermögen benötigen nicht begriffe
benötigen oder sind wir begrifflicher
ist b
das ist halt immer diese propos diese
struktur einmal diese das struktur- und
er ist noch begrifflich das ist dass die
frage ist ob wahrnehmung begrifflich
strukturiert ist
ob tiere begriffe besitzt das ist
alleine riesen diskussion der
philosophie des geistes
erstens mal ganz allgemein auch ein
blick auf die menschen ob wahrnehmung
begrifflich hat nicht begrifflich ist
was nicht begriffliche warnungen gibt
jung vertritt die these dass es nicht
begriffliche erkenntnis oder wahrnehmung
gibt er sagt die ganze also wir können
aus sind es daten jetzt endlich zum
urteil kommen ohne dass der begriff eine
rolle spielen müssen
der begriff wir wären ja dann wieder
eine rationale seite das atrio risches
wir kommen also letztendlich dass solche
dinge postareals endlich sagt jun
ich habe die frage müssen nicht tiere um
zu einem urteil zu gelangen um etwas als
solches erkennt einen begriff davon
haben und an einen konkreten fall den
begriff subsumieren sagen dass hier was
da irgendwie ist der tisch ist deswegen
tisch weil ich dieses objekt hier ohne
den begriff des tisches option ihre
deswegen habe ich die erkenntnis
erkenntnis heißt ja immer ich muss einen
konkreten fall haben der wahrnehmung
genügt aber nicht weil ein fall ist hier
ist dann ein fall wenn oder ein begriff
gebracht wird
ich kann ein objekt ihres als objekt
erkennen wenn ich weiß was für eine art
das ist muss etwas konkret vorliegendes
erst mal konkretisieren und dazu brauche
ich einen allgemeinen begriff stehen sie
ja man muss immer etwas sein das ist ein
solcher fall
dann muss aber den begriff des falls
haben uns sagen stuhl will ich nicht den
stuhl gesehen habt könnt ihr nicht sagen
ist stuhl ich kein begriff des stuhls
habe würden sie dann sagen und ihr habt
begriffe vielleicht oder muster
ja die meisten würden zwar als ich denke
ich mal nicht unbedingt mehr jungen
nicht schön würde das denke ich auch
nicht sagen ich würde nicht sagen dass
erkenntnis begriffe benötigen tiere und
menschen können ohne begriffe zu
besitzen
zur erkenntnis gelangen auf basis der
erfahrung als die erfahrung gibt uns
eine erkenntnis ohne begrifflich
vermittelt
das ist nach junge punkt nur so wie wir
jetzt bei dem hund des beispiel hatten
eines einem druckstopp gibt uns einen
begriff schon etwas oder lässt uns hier
zu einem urteil führen ohne dass wir im
begriff davon haben müssen wir uns sagt
menschen und tiere brauchen keine
begriffe dazu und viele stellen es eben
frage und sagen wir brauchen dazu
begriffe zum beispiel kant immanuel
kants wir brauchen um erkenntnis haben
die wahrnehmung diese ganzen duftstoffe
ich noch sehen empfinden und noch die
begriffe nur anschauen und begriff sein
ergebnis kenntnis jungs sagt anschauen
reicht alleine schon für sich genommen
um zu erkennen es zu gelangen
das also immer die frage sie noch kurzen
dann hätten ja
da ist die frage
oder
habe ich ja trotzdem ventile reaktionen
an meinen aber dass
das liegt
aber weil er den dreh dich erfahren hat
was andres das verhältnis
die möglichkeit dass wir begriffe
erklären jetzt hatten wir mehrere
meldungen hier und dann hier ja nicht
also ein bisschen zirkuläre wäre das
dann dass wir also um überhaupt eine
wahrnehmung von etwas haben zu können
dieses etwas schon wahrgenommen haben
müssen immer schon und dann die frage
ist woher bekommt mit dem begriff ist er
ein geboren oder sowas
also die sind glaube auf den punkt auf
den sieg zu sprechen kamen gerade der
wird häufig verwendet um zu sagen wir
müssen die begriffe apriori schein uns
haben wir können zu begriffen gar nicht
über die erfahrungen kommen so die
müssen vor alle erfahrung sein das sagt
zumindest kant ganztag begriffe müssen
transzendentalen vor einer erfahrung wir
können sie nicht durch die erfahrung
gewinnen weil erfahrungen ist einfach
nicht diese konstanz dieser
begrifflichkeit bietet
[Musik]
wissen
ja also man auch die relativität der
sprache zum beispiel man hat versucht
sprachlich relative aktivitäten
aufzuzeigen
sie kennen vielleicht diese live
prothese in der sprachwissenschaft dass
man sagt bestimmte völker kulturen die
in bestimmten lebensräumen leben die
haben für bestimmte phänomene zum
beispiel für den schnee ganz viele
begriffe während wir hier in
mitteleuropa zu den schnee eben nur ein
begriff haben aber bestimmte völker eben
oder kulturen weil es eben für sie so
wichtig ist dieser bereich die
begrifflichkeit auch stärker analysiert
haben manche sagen es gibt also aufgrund
dieser kaiserlichen umstände auch
begrifflich relativität und nicht alle
begriffe sind gleich eine möglichkeit ja
sollten sie noch gemeldet
zb
sie müssten dann irgendwie müssen sie
dann bickel von man haben ja
muster mustererkennung ja so als
abstraktion letztendlich nicht
als abstraktion wir sehen von allen
wesentlichen eigenschaften ab männer
kennen sich eben typischerweise in
bestimmten dingen und frauenstimmen ding
und dann abstrahieren wir von einem
unwesentlichen haben so muster und das
ist dann unser begriff
manche sagen wie griffe werden ebenso
gebilde durch durch abstraktion an
könnten tiere da nicht auch so ein
begriff entwickeln so spannende frage
lesen noch mal weiter zweiter stützt
sich der schluss dem das tier aus dem
gegenwärtigen eindruck zieht auch bei
ihm auf die erfahrung und genauer gesagt
auf seine beobachtung betreffen die
verbindung der gegenstände in früheren
fällen werden die erfahrungen andere
erschließt es anders das dann einen
schlag das eine mal auf ein bestimmtes
zeichen oder eine bestimmte bewegung
folgt ein anderes mal auf ein anderes
zeichen oder eine andere bewegung so
wird das tier nacheinander verschiedene
schlüsse ziehen
jedes mal der jüngsten erfahrungen
entsprechen also was um was es hier geht
ist vermochte induktions schluss also
von einer endlichen anzahl an
erfahrungen auf eine zukünftige
erfahrung zu schließen
also wenn ich fünf bis zehn mal erlebt
habe immer dieselbe abfolge wenn adam b
dann gehe ich in einem zukünftigen fall
davon aus dass wenn eintritt auch
befolgen wird wenn es zehn oder hundert
mal der vor der fall gewesen war und
diese induktion diese gewöhnung ist für
jung eines der wichtigsten zeichen
unserer vernunft als diese induktions
schluss von einer endlichen anzahl
beobachteter verhältnisse immer wenn
adam b folgt ebenfalls einen zukünftigen
fall wenn eintritt ich auch auf die
schließe das ist versuchen so ein
typisches zeichen der vernunft unserer
gewöhnung zu gewöhnen
er sagt das als ein schluss
noch ein zitat noch man lasse nun aber
einmal einen philosophen die probe
machen und sich abmühen den akt des
geistes den wir glauben zu nehmen den
wir glauben nichts erklären über die
prinzipien auf denen er beruht
rechenschaft zu geben ohne zuhilfenahme
der wirkung der gewohnheit auf die
einbildungskraft man lasse ihn dann
seine hypothese von den menschen
unverändert auf die tiere übertragen ich
verspreche wenn dies gelingt wer seine
ansicht anzueignen
andererseits verlange ich aber als
billige gegenleistung dass er wenn meine
theorie die einzige ist die allen diesen
anforderungen genügt diese als
vollkommen befriedigen und überzeugend
anerkennen dass sie aber die einzige ist
ergibt sich klar fast so eine überlegung
die tiere nehmen sicherlich niemals
irgendeine reale verknüpfung zwischen
gegenstücken war also den adern beta
nehmen sie nichts dazwischen war diese
kausalität relation nehmen sie nicht
wahr
nur die erfahrung lässt sie also von dem
einen gegenstand auf den anderen
gegenstand beschließen
sie können durch keine vernunft gründe
zudem allgemein schluss gelangen dass
diejenigen gegen stellte ihnen in der
form nicht gegeben waren
den gleichen welche gegenstand ihrer
erfahrung waren als er wirkt die
erfahrung auf sie allein durch
vermittlung der gewohnheit
alles dies erschien uns mit rücksicht
auf die menschen genügend evident aber
auch hinsichtlich der tiere kann diese
anschaulich zu der geringst nicht der
geringste verdacht alles wird uns
treffen die es ist wenn man zugeben muss
ein mächtiger bestätigung meiner theorie
oder vielmehr ist es eine unwiderlegbare
beweis für dieselbe nichts zeigt
deutlich wie leicht es die gewohnheit
mit einem tatbestand vertraut macht als
der umstand dass die menschen über die
tätigkeit ihrer eigenen vernunft nicht
erstaunt sind während sie zur gleichen
zeit über dem instinkt der tiere sich
verwundern und die erklärung des
schwierig finden sie verwundern sich
darüber weil bloß weil er nicht auf
genau die gleichen gründe zurückgeführt
werden kann wie jene verstandes
tätigkeit nach das ist also dann doch
nicht dass die ursache
offensichtlich in der tat ist aber wenn
wir die sache recht betrachten auch die
vernunft gar nichts als ein wunderbarer
unfassbare instinkt unserer seele der
uns in einer vorstellungs reihe von
vorstellung zu vorstellung weiterleitet
und diese vorstellung mit bestimmten
eigenschaften ausstatten entsprechend er
jedes mal in stellung und beziehung
derselben untereinander freilich
entsteht dieser distinct aus früher
beobachtung und erfahrung aber ist die
hervorbringung solche wirkungen durch
erfahrung und beobachtung im letzten
grunde verständlicher als die
unmittelbare hervorbringen durch die
natur
was ist die gewohnt was die gewohnheit
kann das kann sicherlich auch die natur
die gewohnheit ist ja eben gar nichts
als eine hand als eine als einer der
wirkenden faktoren der natur schöpft
ihre ganze macht aus dieser quelle
also das ist noch der letzte wichtige
punkt hier nur sachen natur vernunft
gewohnheit gewohnheit und instinkt
er sagt das ist eigentlich irgendwie
alles dasselbe auch die vernunft gar
nichts als ein wunderbarer und
unfassbare instinkt unserer seele ist
der menschliche instinkt könnte man
sagen ja das ist sein argument die
vernunft ist glauben die effekte sie ist
jetzt endlich aus der natur abzuleiten
und das zieht ihre macht aus der natur
das soll zwar für heute gewesen sein der
nächsten sitzung kommen ganz kurz noch
mal auf schopenhauer zu sprechen und
dann aber auch wie bereits angekündigt
auf diesen text von norman mal kommen
über gedankenlos tieren dann bis zur
nächsten sitzung